so you're gonna tell us how you're
backing them not yet we're meeting with
many of the candidates over the next few
days we wanted to give people the
opportunity to set their stall out say
what their vision would be where they
wanted to go what they wanted to do and
see how they dealt with each other in
the hustings now various and what kind
of things are you looking for - someone
for someone to convince you well I think
people sometimes forget that the trade
unions formed the Labour Party and they
used to be a time when they were
considered the political wing of the
trade union movement so a lot of the
movement we've houses 2015 where Ed
Miliband advance work and Jeremy's
driven it further forward we'd like to
see that continue we need to articulate
that voice of ordinary people that the
Conservative Party seemed to have
claimed in the short term because we're
a one topic process but the real message
is about the four million people that
are in poverty 1.5 million people in
destitution those that are in non-work
fo self-employment or zeros contracts we
need to get those people a voice you
were saying now that you want to see
some of the work of jeremy corbyn
continue you of course nominated Jeremy
Corbyn previously and many people see
Rebecca along Bailey as his natural
successor the person who perhaps has the
closest politics to Jeremy Corbyn in the
race you leaning towards her not sure
yet because ultimately people don't seem
to understand membership led
organizations so the Labour Party's a
membership led organisation this process
only delivers the candidates the 550,000
members and one-person one-vote will
then decide which candidate they want
and it's the same with my organisation I
have a board that's called an Executive
Committee we will make recommendations
they will ultimately decide the
nomination of as left to that process it
won't be Mick Whelan what's your own
view do you think that Rebecca Don
Bailey is a strong candidate well
stranger if they're all friends and
colleagues of mine I've worked with many
of them down the years so I'm not going
to say at this moment so I'm a personal
preference I fall leader or deputy
leader it's gonna be difficult for me
afterwards no matter who we choose
facing the people I know well can be
slightly awkward yes now FF of course
and also bat brexit yes how important do
you think it is a labour to reconnect if
you like to some of those communities
particularly the Midlands in the north
we lost a lot of seats who vote as
heavily to leave I think there was a
massive misunderstanding about Labour
Party's policy ultimately
when the policy was saying people were
too stupid to understand when they were
voting no never able to say people are
sooo stupid to understand anything that
could be myself that's to to be to
understand but basically what Labour
said was they would respect the vote
they would then deliver a brexit and
then their version of brexit they'll
give people a choice on I think people
are so exhausted by brexit that the
nuances of going out without a deal or a
poor deal either under trees or Mayor
Boris is even worse deal right didn't
matter at that point they just wanted it
done I mean some of the candidates in
the race push very hard for that second
referendum position something that many
people think Jeremy Corbyn himself was a
little bit skeptical of at the beginning
and how important do you think it is
that the next leader is somebody who
perhaps understands why many people
wanted to leave the EU well I think once
the decision had happened there was a
degree of xenophobia there was a degree
this take back control and the mindset
they went with I think the reality is
that the European Union had become
something that it wasn't promised in 70s
that didn't materialize under social
contract in 1984 under Jack chiraq and
was becoming more and more a federation
of states and people didn't want to
belong to that as it was also for us bit
parochial certainly regulations that
prevented us protecting our steel
industry they allowed us to run our own
railways our own utilities were given
major concern to people both in industry
and elsewhere I mean there's been some
analysis commentators saying that people
like K star only Thornbury representing
London seats backing our second
referendum perhaps out of touch with
some labour voters I think there's a
difficulty if you're an MP or any
elected person like get elected you have
to take in context of you the people
that are electing you and what they want
you to do I hate the voice of my members
do I agree with every policy we create
I'm not quite sure I hunt Center in all
times but if you want to leave
constituency I imagine if you want get
reelected you say the things that you
have to say and I imagine if your honor
remain constituency you do the same
thing and a big part of the manifesto
both at this election and the last one
was in the railways is that red line for
you when you're choosing which
candidates back no it's a major thing
for us because we fought privatisation
what happened over the last 25 years and
we now actually had the Williams report
saying that the model has failed it
never lived what's meant to do which
we'd like to be proof right that no one
seems to recognize us for it
the reality for us is the big thing for
us we want it's an opportunity far
greater than ever before right with the
climate change agenda with the green new
deals that we need to do that the
railways and Transport will form the
courts what we do a modal shift from
road to rail for fro ms/ms transit now
it's the time to do it there has to be
under a system whereby communication was
always one of the four factors of
production anything I've got goods or
services from A to B right was
recognized as good so even if you had to
invest in it well it generates the local
economy in the national economies was
where you've got the benefits from so
there will always be a degree of subsidy
and someone will try I mean one of the
really big things when it comes to the
railways of course is what CHS to the
high-speed rail link we're expecting the
government Commission report into HS due
to be published in the in coming weeks
are you worried by you know some of the
reports and saying that the government
is potentially looking at scrapping at
least part of HS - well it frightens me
I mean we've always scrapped the one
part of it so we pander to the cost
argument there's never been a major
project in UK delivered on time or has
delivered the capacity was meant to do
so when the end one was open it was
always that oversubscribed and we were
about 30 years with behind where we need
to be in there infrastructure building
bones do you have a loon they haven't
that it and they will do the trouble is
if we stopped it would it be cheaper in
future the real problem is HS - should
have started at top in the Scotland
started on the south coast start
building the same time met them in the
middle and regenerated everything it
would regenerated the economy it would
have given a boost to construction and
they were given the platform for us -
instances green new era unfortunately
we're being short-sighted on the fact
that we we can treble our debt to
trillions of pounds under austerity and
not deliver anything for it by actually
investing as traditionally has happened
at times of recession or a post
austerity world seems to be the wrong
thing to do okay and just finally and
before Christmas the government unveiled
these plans to make it unlawful to
strike unless there was a minimum
service provided on the railways and you
said at the time you said this
and hopefully a ship coming in a moment
you basically said this is a declaration
of war it will be rail today and other
industries tomorrow that is Boris
Johnson's threat sorry it's not it's not
appearing there but we've we've read out
so we know what we said and so a you at
war with the government I'm at war with
the ethos of forced labor any form of
indenture or slavery we sign up to is
that what you think the government is
trying to patch that well I think was
what trying to do I think the reality
obvious is that start well known fact
that only Lithuania has worse labor laws
than we do this cradle of democracy this
place of Magna Carta right we under the
Maggie's laws under the trade union bill
we've firstly heard the right of people
to strike we also didn't I'm loving
transparency bill took away their voice
and now you want to take the actual
opportunity strike against bad employers
away this is a strong word that big
strong word and that's because the
strength of feeling and yeah when I talk
to people not just in my industry be
elsewhere
that is the feeling of how it is because
of this change to ensure a minimum
service on the railways if their strikes
yes you think that's a form of slavery I
think it's a form of forced labor I
think if you remove that we have no
right to striking UK now we only have a
right not to be sued we jump through the
multitude of hopes that a point in place
and you know when you look at certain
European countries in the mid 30s
you know the stranglehold on the voice
of civil society the right to strike the
ability of trade unions whatever created
a world in which we don't want to be
there I want to be very very careful
where we go as a society right what do
we want and also put in for a process
something that will just lead to poor
industrial relations in my industry for
the next 20 years by anybody who signs
up to this probably isn't then deliver
the intention wasn't meant to do okay
thank you very much for being on the
show today much appreciated